if you're deeply unhappy instead of
blaming everyone else for it put in the
work to get out of it because you can I
believe in people also people have an
obsession to think things are black and
white
okay you don't get it I'm like okay
you've just thrown up the white flag and
just have decided to live unhappy when
there's a million modern ways to get out
of it
no I think it was just the the Cocoon
that I lived in and this is why I always
talk about like suffocating all the
information like you know I listened to
my mom I listened to positive people
around me and I didn't listen to a lot
of influential family members I had in
my life cousins grandparents like things
of that nature and friends I just
limited envy and jealousy and I leaned
into optimism and gratitude and I've
been practicing it for 40 [__] years
and here I am but what I've seen that
really inspires the [__] out of me which
is why I'm making this comment on this
video is
I've watched people
who for 37 years or 18 years or 22 years
be the opposite come into our world or
other people's worlds or marry someone
who's positive and grateful and I've
watched them shift their perspective
humans are byproducts of the information
and the energy they decide to consume
this is why I get so crazy just about
like people who want to like stay in
unhappiness like if you're unhappy if
you're deeply unhappy instead of blaming
everyone else for it put in the work to
get out of it because you can I believe
in people
this is not like you're an [__] dude
you know like you're a bad guy like you
go figure you [__] no this is like I
[__] believe in you like you can do
it right dust
yes sir you believe that right
try all the time right and you believe
that everyone has different levels of
talent to be able to pull it off but us
within our own selves have the capacity
to move the ball down the field and
choose it and be a little bit better
than before
Avi do you feel obvi that you are more
optimistic and like positive because
we've been around each other
absolutely truly nope don't [__] in
your heart yeah mainly because it's just
the energy that's always around
do you think it just seeps we haven't
really talked like that but the energy
of the life experience uh
it's all positive
and I truly believe like any one of us
can overcome anything
we just probably need a little push or
encouragement or Serendipity or the luck
of the draw of getting into an
environment that's that way but then
when I say the luck of the draw one can
create their luck by acknowledging right
in this minute as you watch this [__]
video or listen to it on podcast that
you're like a kid like everyone has a
[__] moment it gets really cozy to
blame Perfection for not doing it oh you
don't get it Julian I'm a perfectionist
that's why I can't put out this video
that's why I'm not starting my
photography career I'm a perfectionist
no you're not you're cute with your
words and you're using as an excuse to
not do because you fear failure
you're not a perfectionist you're of an
avoider their scales get reset they're
they they're starting at negative five
instead of at zero so them getting to
just negative two yeah is great I agree
in that position because that's what
they do for so long yeah they find
Comfort but what they're doing is
they're avoiding accountability
fear
[__] hate fear man
boy do I [__] hate fear boy do I hate
fear
yeah that's like the Perfection thing
it's not about being a perfectionist
you're afraid to fail 100
and it's a cute version you don't have
the humility to admit that you're scared
so you created this real pretty package
called Perfection boy do I get triggered
when people say I'm a perfectionist
I get triggered and it's funny not anger
deep empathy I'm like wow you're deeply
scared and you've manipulated yourself
and others to to hide that you're scared
thank you
[Music]
it's really easy to be like well my mom
[__] me I'm like but you're 37 you're
29 you're 44. like why are you just
gonna be like I got [__] like like
everyone got [__] this is the other
thing people just decided that everyone
else's life is perfect
like you have no idea what's going on in
someone's head or there are four walls
behind their door they have it better
you [__] me what about putting it on
yourself
just using half that energy dude I'm
telling you this is why accountability
is falling it's all a time that lady
just now earlier right you saw her she
was like I heard you speak and four
months later I did like it seemed what
she was trying to say to me was I was
there but then you gave like I just
heard you say it do it and I was like it
was my that that was my time and we're
all affected by that
really
a specific exact second where you're
like okay I'll fight for it
or something different or you mean by
quitting my job
happened with me specifically yeah
yeah like and like by the way I'm just
one human there's [__] lots of people
doing different versions of this
for health and wellness for mental
health for physical health for I mean
just like lots of things it's just like
if you want to find positivity it's
everywhere there's just way too much
momentum right now of people looking for
a negativity
also people have an obsession to think
things are black and white
okay you don't get it I'm like okay
[Music]
you've just thrown up the white flag and
just have decided to live unhappy when
there's a million modern ways to get out
of it
literally making a playlist of positive
songs and just listening to it every
morning for an hour
fundamentally can shift someone
just that go to [__] Spotify and type
in positive like